my name is Michelle Darnell and I am the
wealthiest woman in America how wealthy
am i I wanted to come down on a golden
Phoenix and I sure as [ __ ] did it I run
your operation while being a single mom
I deserve a pay raise you have a child
yeah that's true intercourse yes I
usually get kind of an asexual vibe I
never pictured it with genitals myself
you're under arrest for insider trading
you're bankrupt all your accounts have
been frozen clear get me a new lawyer
you don't have any money you stupid
ginger Ryan if she doesn't have anywhere
to go she should stay here look at that
babe in the sofa careful it's a bit
temperamental it's not so bad you need
to get off the couch take Rachel to her
dandelions meeting are two key men with
the hundred and eighty nine thousand
dollars holy [ __ ] I am jacked two
parolees attending our meeting if you
get off my back I'm gonna shove a box of
chocolate clusters up that tight ass of
yours what is all this this is my way
back we are gonna start a brownie Empire
and teach these girls real business
skills we want some good recruits get in
there go for the aggressive girls feel
kind of sweaty and scared it's just the
coffee kicking in oh you know where oh I
may have switched them they put a little
splash of bourbon in mine
my name is Michelle Darnell and this is
my partner and I don't mean partner like
girl-on-girl stuff let's go on go stir
something you're gonna dabble with in
college but not stick with I know
don't tell less your Hannah I think it's
gonna fit you like a glove okay crystal
what do we say if somebody doesn't want
to buy buy my brownies or I'll kill you
don't say that hey this is where
dandelion self [ __ ] that sweater just
says I give up you're making me feel
very insecure right before my date
don'ts if you could hear these sad
basset hounds may be saying clear order
so bub that's not a sound he's gonna set
me up in your jeans let me see this Oh
Clara
it's like Geppetto but I know it's not
like me
therefore citation mr. hunter a slave
miss than a high leadership for most
kind of an an outlandish